hey kids it's everybody's favorite
whipping boy of a critical term it's
ludonarrative dissonance off the top
here this is ultimately going to be a
defense of ludonarrative dissonance as a
critical concept as a tool for
descriptive criticism but first a bit of
backstory ludonarrative dissonance as a
term was coined by Clint Hocking in a
2007 blog post titled ludonarrative
dissonance in Bioshock the problem of
what the game is about in the post Clint
argues that there is a disconnect
between the story told by the game's
mechanical interactions and the story
told by the game's narrative interaction
that while the game appears to
thematically criticize Randy and
objectivism as a foundational philosophy
and works this criticism into the games
interactions the same doesn't hold true
for the games fiction quote yet in the
game's fiction on the other hand I do
not have that freedom to choose between
helping Atlas or not under the ludecke
contract if I accept to and adopt an
Objectivist approach I can harvest
little sisters if I reject that approach
I can rescue them under the story if I
reject an Objectivist approach I can
help Atlas and oppose Ryan and if I
choose to adopt an Objectivist approach
well too bad I can stop playing the game
but that's about it
this idea of pointing out when a game's
mechanics are being dissonant with a
game's fiction enjoyed a brief period
where it was all the rage the hot new
thing to point to in games and
subsequent to that it also saw pushback
and reevaluation of its value as a
concept on his series errant signal
Chris Franklin aka campster described it
this way in his 2015 video the debate
that never took place like story and
play both exist in service to the
overall work not as two forces in
conflict with one another so why do we
frame them that way it'd be like going
to the movies and then afterwards
talking with friends about how the film
worked is a story and then talking about
how the film worked as an example of
cinematography but never at the same
time you'd never do that and definitely
not in a way that would posit a film as
cinema narrative Lee
now I love that video and I love that
clip in particular for a couple reasons
first that video as a whole makes a
great point about the need for games
criticism to accept games as a whole
text that we should evaluate games not
as a collection of systems on one side
and a collection of fiction on the other
but as a coherent whole that either
works or doesn't in particular Chris is
concerned with this approach to games
criticism especially the forms of game
criticism that exist in reviews that
very much compartmentalize the two
phases of the game in a way that will
lead to discussing games as great
gameplay but the story sucks or a great
story shame about the gameplay and on
this front I should say yes I agree we
should as a baseline treat games as a
whole text if the story is bad and
doesn't set up coherent themes or if it
is ugly dehumanizing and insulting then
that should count as a mark against the
game no matter how fun it is to bend
bullets
however in calling for that sort of
holistic approach critics have
inadvertently tossed the baby out with
the bathwater which brings me to the
second thing that I loved about that
previous clip Chris has in setting up a
counter example accidentally created a
great mechanism for criticism because
there absolutely are films that I would
describe as cinema narrative Lee
dissonant transformers for one by the
text of the script for the two films
that she is in the character of Mikaela
Bane's is smart funny talented driven
hard-working
quick thinking courageous and mature she
is an active agent in the plot she comes
up with plans and her personal arc
meshes with the rest of the film the
simple fact that she is a mechanic gives
her more somatic connection to the
Transformers than anything going on with
Sam however the camera treats Mikaela as
a piece of meat people perceive her as
being superfluous I candy as nagging as
irrational because that is how she is
consistently framed the cinematography
is not strictly speaking bad
it is in its own sphere competent and
well executed
Michaela's writing simultaneously is not
bad but they are not in agreement with
each other there is cinema narrative
dissonance there the story told by the
camera does not agree with the one being
told by the script I actually think that
right there is a great conceptual tool
for critics to use to describe why
something that is technically proficient
on the whole isn't working and within
games criticism I think the idea of
ludonarrative dissonance is a valuable
tool that complements a holistic
approach to games criticism rather than
two tracks from it because it makes it
easier to describe when the story is
telling one message and the mechanics
are telling another now taken as a whole
this kind of dissonance is less common
in film film as a medium is more mature
the language is more established and the
production methods have generally worked
out most of the kinks in terms of
getting everyone involved on the same
page in terms of theme and tone that's
not so much the case in games even
asking about the themes of gameplay the
story told by mechanical interactions is
still a really new idea most filmmakers
today have learned the grammar of film
by virtue of growing up watching films
made by filmmakers who grew up watching
films made by filmmakers who's tinkered
around asking themselves questions about
theme and story and structure and tone
with video games we are right now still
in that first wave of creators and
critics and readers who are asking
questions like what story is the
gameplay telling and because games are
often made in compartmentalised ways
with the writers over here and the
designers over there it is simply more
common for the two disciplines to tell
different stories Clint's example still
stands it's not that the fiction of
Bioshock is bad or that the gameplay is
awful but simply that the two aren't in
agreement with each other to me the idea
of ludonarrative dissonance gives us a
way to acknowledge when both teams have
done their jobs well in isolation but
have perhaps failed to support
each other or whoever has led the
project has failed to keep everyone
pointed towards the same thematic tonal
goal so what do you think let me know in
the comments if you think the idea of
dissonance is a valuable critical tool
for descriptive criticism or are they
just like games man
[Music]